Gaza is burning there's an ethnic
cleansing campaign happening right now
many westerners are experiencing for the
first time a chapter in a story much
older and more complex than meets the
eye but not as old or as complex as
you'd think I'm Tristan and today we're
uncovering the untold story of Israel
and Palestine Amit this latest
humanitarian Nightmare and
many people have found themselves
stupified by the actions taken and the
positions supported by leaders and
States it's enough to make you think
that you've gone crazy somehow to help
me out with this video I've teamed up
with maybe the most intelligent guy I
know on the subject to ensure that you
know everything about the history of
this conflict and how we got to such a
dark place we should dive in with a
historical overview give you context and
let you understand the whole situation
and how we got to where we are today I
once heard a rumor that I'm a history
YouTuber so this should be theoretically
your jam The conflict's Roots can
probably be traced to the late 19th or
early 20th centuries specifically to the
beginning of the Zionist movement at its
beginning Zion was a movement that
advocated for a Jewish homeland in
response to Growing anti-Semitism in
Europe the first inklings of conflict
began when Jewish zionists migrated to
the Ottoman Empire because at that time
the Ottomans controlled what would be
modern day Israel the West Bank and Gaza
we saw small but significant land
disputes between Jews and Arabs but the
big moment that solidified the Imperial
powers of Europe would assist the Jewish
people of Europe in making a state for
themselves happened during World War I
when the Ottoman Empire was in freef
fall and European powers were taking
over their Holdings in the Middle East
the big moment was the bow for
Declaration of
1917 which pledged to establish a
national home for the Jewish people in
Palestine which again at that point was
under British
control following the Sykes Pico
agreement which was essentially Britain
and France carving up the Middle East
amongst themselves British foreign
secretary Arthur balfor authored the
balfor Declaration surprise surprise he
addressed it to Lord Walter Rothchild a
prominent figure in the British Jewish
Community the Declaration was a
significant political commitment it was
just one sentence 67 words long that
announced that the British were going
going to support the establishment of a
quote National home for the Jewish
people in Palestine his Majesty's
government view will favor The
Establishment in Palestine of a national
home for the Jewish people and will use
their best Endeavors to facilitate the
achievement of this object it being
clearly understood that nothing should
be done which may Prejudice the civil
and religious rights of existing
non-jewish communities in Palestine all
the rights and political status enjoyed
by Jews in any other country it did
promise support for a Jewish National
home but also made sure to include
subclauses regarding the civil and
religious rights of the existing
non-jewish communities in Palestine
already they were attempting to do a bit
of a balancing act they already
understood that British Imperial
interests in the region and Zionist
National Ambitions and the indigenous
Arab populations was going to cause some
complexity the Declaration resulted from
a sustained effort by the Zionist
organization which started in 1897 under
leader Theodore hurel and was a
significant victory in the process
towards establishing a Jewish state in
Palestine immediately though it became
controversial many non-zionist Jewish
circles in Europe thought that it
ignited conflicts of loyalty furthermore
this was the found Keystone for the
Israeli Palestinian conflict as we know
it today the Declaration received
endorsement from all the Allied powers
of World War I and even had the prior
approval from rudro Wilson the president
of the United States who had been
sympathetic with the Zionist cause not
for any like you know high-minded reason
but because a lot of these European
powers really liked the idea of all of
the Jews
leaving their country in the Years
following the Declaration though the
British government started to see that
tension and unrest were already being a
little bit too much to handle they began
to recommend limits on Jewish
immigration to Palestine unless resident
Palestinian Arabs consented to further
immigration so many Zionist leaders went
to different countries to gain more
support for allowing more Jewish
immigration into the Mandate it was the
beginning of the establishment of the
state of Israel and also the beginning
of ongoing disputes over land and
sovereignty that continue to this day as
the Bal for declaration laid the
groundwork for these developments the
focus then shifted into what would come
after the war the creation of mandatory
Palestine this geopolitical entity
emerged under British Administration
following the first world war and set
the stage for the complex and turbulent
evolution of the region into what would
today become modern Israel and Palestine
so let's talk about that after World War
I in the early 20th century the League
of Nations which you can kind of think
of as the prequel to The United Nations
instituted a mandate system that would
administer what they called non
self-governing territories these were
large parts of the former Ottoman Empire
and Imperial Germany that had not been
countries of their own before it was a
very um European imperialist idea the
concept was that European Empires who
knew how to manage countries properly
would administer these places preparing
them for self-governance and
Independence if you you think that
sounds extremely infantilizing to the
people of the Middle East and parts of
Africa that's because you're correct
it's extremely infantilizing that's
precisely what it is the British mandate
for Palestine was one of these and was
established in 1920 to become effective
on September 29th 1923 the Mandate
formalize that the British controlled
parts of the Levant including the
territories of Israel and Palestine the
implementation of the British mandate
passed by the League of Nations in
1922 Incorporated principles of the
balfor Declaration and included in the
documents founding it that the British
would support quote a national home for
the Jewish people this mandate didn't
alter the Region's borders but it did
affirm that the British would control
the territories of Palestine and trans
Jordan in the document that made the
Mandate they explicitly acknowledged
that the Jewish people had a historical
connection with Palestine and that the
British would facilitate the
establishment of a Jewish National home
in the region of course the
implementation of this mandate LED
immediately to even more tensions and
more conflict fueled by the fact that
the Palestinians and the new Jews who
are arriving had different Ing and
conflicting National Ambitions and had
different claims to important holy
landmarks or territories this less than
ideal circumstance led to widespread
protests riots and revolts furthermore
the mandate system was not unfairly
criticized for many things one of them
being that the mandate system was
perceived as being focused on the
interests of a external population I.E
Jewish immigrants moving to the region
and didn't seem super interested in the
local inhabitants of that territory who
already live there so already mandatory
Palestine was a hotbed of conflicts
violence and riots and it was just
overall a nightmare for the British
Administration however the world was on
the brink of another monumental Earth
shaking event the second world war this
almost feels like it's redundant to say
but the second world war profoundly
influenced the course of Jewish National
movements and the identity of Jewish
people worldwide in case you're
literally a baby or you have never read
a single book ever during the second
world war 6 million Jews were killed by
the German Nazi regime this genocide
campaign called the Holocaust was of ES
scale and horror that most people
couldn't even conceive of let alone
figure out what to do about it
afterwards to say the least it led to a
significant shift in international
sentiment after the war the
International Community started to more
and more support creating a Jewish State
and thought that it was a necessity to
create a Haven for Jewish people and now
it had a renewed urgency a moral
imperative again
rather than addressing anti-Semitism in
their own countries or making that
Refuge their countries by accepting them
they instead went to mandatory Palestine
this change in attitude was a turning
point so then what were the British to
do how do you figure out how to create
this Jewish homeland in a place like
Palestine a place that's ancient that
has many conflicting claims that has a
large indigenous population that in
insists on living all over the place and
carve it up in a way so that everybody
gets to be happy it went before the
United Nations on November 29th 1947 and
the general assembly legally allowed for
the formation of what would be called
Israel the plan would divide Palestine
into a Jewish State and an Arab state
but also make an internationally
administered Zone specifically for
Jerusalem because Jerusalem as a city is
is an extremely holy place for Jews
Muslims and Christians alike there was
no great way to implement this plan
though that satisfied really anyone the
response to this plan of course was not
exactly loved Arab leaders rejected this
plan outright for several key reasons
firstly there was fundamental opposition
to the creation of a Jewish state in any
part of Palestine which the Arabs who
helped the Allies defeat the Ottoman
Empire
saw as a betrayal the proposed plan
allocated 56% of the land to the Jewish
State despite the Palestinian population
outnumbering the Jewish population by a
significant margin they saw this
division of land as unjust failing to
represent the demographic realities on
in the region moreover Arab leaders
opposed it on grounds fueled by various
militant positions stemming from
religious and nationalist ideologies
these were the people they Allied who
would be nationalist revolters against
the Ottoman Empire after all the concept
of partitioning Palestine itself was
just unacceptable to Arab leadership who
had rejected similar schemes in the past
additionally they also viewed it as an
imposition on their land and their
sovereignty a sentiment supported across
the Arab world in contrast Zionist
leaders publicly supported it still it
was pretty well known that there were
private Expressions that the plan was to
eventually control all of historic
Palestine in the long term beneran a
pragmatist was generally willing to
accept a partition and the establishment
of a Jewish state in part of the country
although throughout he remained
committed to a vision of Jewish
sovereignty over all of Palestine as the
ultimate goal of Zionism extreme sides
of conflict aside the British mandate
ended and anyway in 1948 with the
creation of the state of Israel
proclaimed on May 14th of that year the
Declaration of Israel and the reaction
to the UN partition immediately sparked
what they called the first Arab Israeli
War as you can guess when I say the
first arab-israeli war you know that
we're in for a rocky few decades
immediately the Arab Israeli War broke
out on May 14th 1948 it's known as the
war of independence for for Israelis and
as the Naka or catastrophe for
Palestinians the War was between the
newly established state of Israel and a
coalition of Arab States including Egypt
trans Jordan Syria and expeditionary
forces from Iraq most importantly for
this conflict is that the war resulted
in what the Palestinians as I said
earlier call the Noba which was the mass
displacement of
700,000 Palestinians where Israeli
troops either kick them out of their
homes or they simply fled on their own
to other countries many into refugee
camps that lasted for decades some of
them are still open to this day the War
lasted until 1949 and it ended with an
Armistice agreement between Israel and
the Arab states in the war Israel
captured approximately 78% of the
mandate's territory taking significant
land the UN had set aside for Arabs
Jordan annexed the West Bank and Egypt
took control of the Gaza Strip however
nobody was happy with this resolution
and it did not resolve any of the
underlying issues that caused the war in
the first place so it merely set the
scene for another conflict in the region
later it also caused a massive Refugee
crisis tons of unresolved political
issues and a very charged tense
atmosphere in the Middle East this
tension coupled with the ongoing dispute
over territory led to the outbreak of
the Six Day War in 1967 the sixday war
also known as the 1967 Arab Israeli War
or the third Arab Israeli War lasted for
as name implies 6 days again it was a
conflict between Israel and a coalition
of Arab states specifically Egypt Jordan
or I guess CIS Jordan now and Syria The
War Began because during the growing
political tensions and Military buildup
Egypt started sending troops to the
Sinai penin P insula this little dingly
thing right here right on the border
with Israel Israel then actually
instigated the war This Time by
launching a preemptive strike against
Egypt the Israeli Air Force targeted
Egyptian airfields and quickly gained
air superiority which made the entire
war effort fall apart Jordan and Syria
entered into the war but Israel was
successfully able to repel their attacks
and Then followed it up with a
successful counter offense and again
remarkably under a week Israel had
defeated three Arab countries armies as
a result of this war Israel started
occupying lots of new territory
including the sidai peninsula the Gaza
Strip the West Bank and East Jerusalem
which is the half of Jerusalem set aside
for Palestinians also and the Golden
Heights these territories represented
Israel quadrupling in size and led to
another Mass ethnic cleansing campaign
displacing approximately
413,000 Palestinians this newly captured
territory during the 6 day war became a
point of contention for neighboring
countries it ended with yet another
ceasefire but still failed to resolve
any of the underlying issues so it was
only a matter of time before yet another
war broke out this would be the yam
kapor War of 1973 sometimes known as the
October War this conflict lasted from
October 6th to the 25th the first shot
this time was a surprise attack by Egypt
and Syria against Israel on the Jewish
holy day of yam Kapur which also
coincided with the Islamic holy month of
Ramadan the initial success of the
attack allowed Egypt's forces to cross
the Suz canal and for Syrian troops to
breach Israeli positions but by by
October 24th Israeli forces had
counterattacked effectively encircled
the Egyptian third Army and had Advanced
closing in on Cairo the United States
and the Soviet Union teamed up to force
an end to the war on October 25th
1973 this time though there wouldn't be
more and more ongoing Wars they decided
that that was enough and they needed to
make a more permanent solution to the
problem so the yam kapor War resulted in
what were called the Camp David Accords
which ended up being signed by Egyptian
president anoir Sadat and Israeli Prime
Minister menim beIN beginning on
September 17th 1978 US President Jimmy
Carter brokered the deal these Accords
resulted from 12 days of secret
negotiations and created quite an
intense peace treaty they established a
bilateral peace agreement and a formula
for Palestinian autonomy within the West
Bank and Gaza Strip and Egypt also got
the Sinai Peninsula back congratulations
yay look at your little thing so after
the Y kapore War we got the Camp David
Accords which created a uh relative
period of peace and calm however it
still didn't solve any of the underlying
tensions in Israel because the fact is
that Israel is a country built on top of
another country with people in it who
want to live the Camp David Accords
didn't do much about that whole
situation it gave a little bit of
Palestinian autonomy but it didn't
resolve anything about the status of the
territory that Israel was now occupying
however it did mean that the
Palestinians living under occupation had
lost any national actors acting as
allies on their behalf this piece was
the beginning of a new phase of the
conflict as Palestinians now knew they
were on their own it turned from a
series of Wars to a series of uprisings
and revolts often known as intifadas the
first one breaking out in 1987 so this
first inata sometimes known as the
Palestinian Uprising began on December
9th 1987 after a fatal Collision
happened in the Gaza Strip this incident
ignited widespread Pro protest
demonstrations and acts of Civil
Disobedience against Israeli occupation
in the Gaza Strip West Bank and East
Jerusalem Palestinians fought back with
boycotts strikes work refusal in Israel
confrontations with Israeli forces also
characterized this period Palestinians
used Stones Molotov cocktails and only
very occasionally got their hands on
some Firearms this inap was primarily a
Grassroots movement but it soon came
under the organization of the unified
National leadership of the uprising
which then worked as a sort of de facto
government of the uprising the first
inapa created a leading role for the
Palestinian Liberation Organization or
PLO which was based out of Tunis and
also saw the rise of islamist groups
that were not secular like the PLO and
were EXP licitly religious militants
groups like Hamas the first inapa
resulted in the death of approximately
1,00 Palestinians and 16 Israeli
civilians we'll talk a lot about scale
and power dynamics a little bit later
and that but that number should really
give you an idea of how things are going
to play out the inapa continued until
September of 1993 with the signing of
the Oslo Accords the Oslo Accords was
this period marked by attempts to find
some lasting peace between the Israelis
and the Palestinians living under
Israeli occupation these meetings led to
two agreements they signed the first in
1993 and the second in
1995 they were crucial for various
reasons the biggest being the formal
recognition of each other between Israel
and the PLO Oslo 1 signed on September
13th 1993 introduced an ATT to build
even the ground rules for resolving the
conflict through talks instead of
violence the PLO recognized Israel's
existence and Israel committed to
withdrawing from parts of Gaza and the
West Bank to allow for Palestinian
self-government it also set up a 5-year
interim period where during this period
they would then negotiate a more
permanent peace settlement during these
five years they then signed Oslo 2 which
would provide further details on
self-governing arrangements for the
Palestinians including dividing the West
Bank into various control areas also
they addressed elections civil and legal
Affairs and bilateral cooperation
between the two it also led to the
creation of the Palestinian Authority
and the election of yaser Arafat as the
president the Palestinian Authority is
the dejour government for the
Palestinians and functions as such to
various degrees mostly in the West Bank
to this day Israeli troops were also
redeployed from parts of Gaza Jericho
and the West Bank away from different
Villages and towns giving them slightly
more control over their land the problem
though is that the Accords faced
opposition and criticism from both sides
because they didn't address many vital
issues like the status of Jerusalem or
the right of return for Palestinian
refugees Israel had not provided any
pathway for Palestinians expelled during
the 1948 and 1967 Wars to return to
their homes it was actively expanding
illegal settlements into the occupied
territory of the West Bank this problem
continues to this day Palestinians still
can't go home is
still building illegal settlements in
the West Bank Israelis will go into the
West Bank set up these illegal
settlements that you know shouldn't
exist and on land that Israel has no
right to occupy and frequently in the
process displaces Palestinians when
Palestinians respond to that action the
Israeli government comes down hard with
troops bullets tear gas whatever they
want there's violence there's killing
and let's just say the Palestinians
never really come up on top in these
situations Israel also began restricting
Palestinian movement and doubled down on
expanding these settlements in the West
Bank one of the things that killed this
peace process was was the assassination
in 1995 of Israeli Prime Minister Yak
Rabin who was a strong proponent of them
and and while they put in interim
measures the Accords didn't lead to any
other peace agreement the 5 years passed
and all of the temporary CLA is had to
just become the status quo it was also
further derailed by the outbreak of the
still the peace process was already well
off track by that point and very fragile
the second inut was much more violent
than the first representing a
significant escalation of the conflict
to this day though there were some
efforts to try and revive it the Oslo
Accords are seen as a failed attempt to
create peace at this point it's created
more disillusion with the peace process
and escalated tensions more than it did
anything on a permanent basis I guess
you could say its main result was the
second inata sometimes the second inata
goes by the name of the AL AXA inata
which lasted from 2000 until 2005 a
visit to the AL oxa mosque by Ariel
Chiron a candidate for prime minister
sparked this Uprising as Palestinians
perceived this act as provocative and
many times when you're reading about
this reaction to Ariel chiron's visit
the Palestinian anger over the incident
gets written off as religious zealotry
either that or some kind of irrational
anger but I wanted to look into the
context of this because it's essential
to understand why these things happen I
tend to go by a truism in my head and
and I always try to keep it on my
shoulder people do things for reasons so
the AL oxa mosque is situated on the
Temple Mount also known as the Haram al-
Sharif in East Jerusalem many
International entities and countries
recognize this area as part of the
Palestinian territories it's also a site
of profound religious significance to
both Muslims and Jews for Muslims this
site is the third holiest in all of
Islam while for Jews it is the holiest
because it is the location of the
ancient Jewish temples chiron's visit to
the highly sensitive religious site
governed by numerous peacekeeping rules
was perceived as a political move
asserting Jewish claims over this
disputed area Ariel Shone was a
controversial figure to say the least
among Palestinians because he's mainly
known known for his role in the 1982
Sabra and chatila Massacre during
Israel's invasion of Lebanon so with all
that context his visit to the AL AXA
mosque was probably seen through the
prism of the fact that he had a
reputation for being a brutal and bloody
conqueror as well as a Hardline Israeli
figure his visit occurred on September
28th 2000 during heightened tensions
amidst a failing peace process Chiron
accompanied by a substantial number of
Israeli Riot police and iron bodyguards
made a visit that many perceived as
deliberate and an assertive show of
force the visit sparked protests and
riots among the Palestinians who again
viewed it as a deliberate attempt to
inflame tensions and undermine
Palestinian claims to East Jerusalem the
clashes that ensued involved Stone
throwing by the Palestinian Ians which
was then responded to with tear gas and
rubber bullets by the Israeli police
this Uprising featured both non-violent
protests and armed struggles there were
Palestinians who organized protests
against military campaigns settlements
home demolitions and the construction of
the separation barrier which we'll get
to in a second but also had people who
used firearms and commed suicide bombing
Israel's Defense Forces or the IDF
responded by basically invading
Palestine and mass murder approximately
3,000 Palestinians and about 1,000
Israelis died in the process during this
period Israel constructed this
monstrosity the separation wall in the
West Bank and in doing so annexed
massive tracks of Palestinian land to
build it on also during the inata yaser
Arafat died in 2004 and Mahmud abas
became the new leader of the PLO in 2005
Israel withdrew its soldiers and
settlers from Gaza and while that sounds
like a victory the withdrawal allowed
Israel to intensify its military
operations in Gaza they withdrew their
people so they could rely heavier on
just carpet bombing places the brutal
destruction and heavy militarization of
Gaza after the second inat turned it
into an ABS abolute nightmare this
Devastation would surprisingly lead to
extreme reactions which would happen in
2007 when Hamas took control of the Gaza
Strip Hamas formerly known as and I
apologize to all my Arabic viewers
harakat al- mukama Al islamia or Islamic
resistance movement has become a
prominent figure in Palestinian politics
and conflict Dynamics founded during the
First Palestinian Uprising in 1987 as an
offshoot of the Muslim brotherhood's
Palestinian Branch hamas's emergence
marked a strategic shift towards armed
resistance against Israel and the
aspirations for an Islamic Palestinian
State this ideological stance contrasts
with the more secular approach of the
fat party which had previously dominated
Palestinian Politics the 2006
Palestinian legislative elections were a
turning point Hamas achieved a decisive
Victory securing 44% of the vote and
winning 76 of the 132 seats in
Parliament the Electoral success of
Hamas not only signified a Powers shift
from fat to Hamas but also indicated a
move towards more islamist and militant
perspectives in Palestinian governance
the following year in 2007 Hamas
capitalized on the weakening of
Palestinian Authority forces in G
effectively seizing control of the
region this takeover further cemented
hamas's role as the de facto governing
entity in the Gaza Strip however the
rise of Hamas has not been without
consequences to say the least the
group's commitment to arm resistance
against Israel has led to increased
tensions to say the least and conflicts
to say the least including the
deployment of various attack methods
like improvised explosive devices
rockets and mortars internationally many
countries including the United States
and the European Union have designated
Hamas as a terrorist organization this
designation has led to economic
sanctions and restrictions on Aid
exacerbating the already difficult
living conditions in the Gaza Strip this
change in power power also created a lot
more divisions between different
factions of Palestinians because now
secular Palestinians and the islamist
militants would be in contention this
takeover led to Israel fortifying its
border against Gaza and turning it into
what is today called an open air prison
gazin can't leave Israel effectively
blockades their trade it is not a great
situation and it has just been
escalating in the Years since we had
operation castled or the first Gaza War
which happened in 2008 to 2009 as a
response to Rocket attacks from Gaza in
2014 another conflict resulted in a
ceasefire but there were significant
casualties in the meantime in 2021 East
Jerusalem and Gaza had an escalation in
violence that ended with a ceasefire
still most recently as I'll get to later
in this video there's the current
conflict that started in October of last
year which is one of the biggest
escalations in many many many years if
not the entire history of the country
but it's essential to know as we've
talked about this whole time that these
conflicts are over land and territory
and wanting to survive it's not
primarily about religion but National
self-determination it's about
sovereignty so that's the historical
context of this whole big ass conflict
let's go a little bit more personal I
want to introduce you guys to Jeremy at
this point in the video so Jeremy he has
a unique experience and deep insights
into the complexities of the conflict
especially from the Viewpoint of being a
North American Jewish man who has spent
a significant portion of of his life
advocating for Palestinian rights Jeremy
and I went to grad school together
studying American studies but the reason
I wanted to talk to him is because
Jeremy knows more about the situation
than anybody I know so let's just bring
him up I was raised in a very uh zionis
uh household in the Jewish community in
Toronto my grandmother was an awit
Survivor she kept her uh number
tattoo understandably so
as a uh Testament to what was done to
her right in in in as an education tool
and so people talk about Holocaust
Education now and people who aren't
learning about the Holocaust in schools
and I just I mean that was something
I've always been aware of right from
from the day I was born and uh my
grandmother and my other relatives I
well were as well were staunch uh
Zionist right to them that was the only
way to prevent something like the
Holocaust from occurring again was to
have this
fortified Jewish homeland uh in in the
Middle East and so this was something I
I had internalized I went to Israel for
the first time with my family when I was
nine almost 10 uh it this summer uh
right before the second inap broke out
didn't really know anything about the
conflict beyond what I was told that
this is just Arab hostility towards
Israel is just another
manifestation of this uh ancient hatred
of anti-Semitism that just continually
uh recurred uh throughout history but
there was talk that there was going to
be peace and I didn't really examine it
much beyond that I met my Israeli
cousins they were quite nice
and yeah it was great I mean I just
remember how excited I was as like a
9-year-old I guess when uh my parents
told me that we're were going to Israel
it was to actually celebrate my
grandfather's 80th birthday and there's
I think a sense of like Euphoria when
you land in in the Israeli airport which
is uh built on the ruins of a
Palestinian Village that was uh wiped
out in 19 48 just seeing all these signs
in Hebrew welcoming you seeing
McDonald's with like a Hebrew menu and
even things like you see Ultra Orthodox
Jewish uh like Street musicians right
and it's just sort of everywhere and it
does feel very welcoming and inviting
for you as a young Jewish person who
doesn't really understand the process by
which that environment was created
through this this process of
militaristic social engineering that
drove out Palestinians most of the
Palestinians and not all of them and uh
brought in Jews from all over the world
and when you're I went to a Jewish Day
School as a kid too so that was another
sort of place where this this attachment
to the state of Israel was inculcated in
me uh from a very young age it's just
like kind of like a dream come true
really when you're experiencing that as
as a kid so a lot of history and local
and Regional politics are super
important for understanding why conflict
accelerates so quickly when it happens
in Palestine so first of all Israel is
in the middle of the Middle East and the
Middle East has a complicated background
and a bunch of regional rivalries the
biggest one would be the tension between
a group of Western allies notably Israel
the UAE and Saudi Arabia
against Iran and Iran friendly countries
like Syria and Iraq and a lot of the
regions geopolitics revolve around this
Central struggle and very often when
violence breaks out in Gaza or the West
Bank these countries get blamed for
either eing it on or intervening or
secretly funding or something to that
extent and frequently that's used to
justify even more violence or an even
more brutal response to anything that
happens Israel is a staunch Western Ally
which has to be one of the largest
understatements of the last 100 years
Israel gets a pretty good deal out of
this relationship with the US which is
that American power especially at the
United Nations covers them from pretty
much all consequences of their actions
anything they do to Palestinians
including war crimes use of banned weap
weapons and nuclear
proliferation has happened with
basically no consequences domestically
we've also seen Israel go through many
changes in the last few decades since
the yam Kapur War Israel's politics have
been shifting more and more towards the
far right you could probably track the
beginning of this with the election of
menim beIN in
1977 because bein's party is now the
party in control of the country in the
current crisis you might wonder how
Israel has any like guards or you know
railings against like all the violence
that's happening well the ruling lud
party which is Benjamin netanyahu's
party as well is one of the most
far-right Israeli parties it is the most
powerful mainstream right-wing parties
and has definitely gone into coalitions
with more far-right parties but it's
still very rightwing since 1977 Israel
has moved towards a more centralized and
less checked power base in 2023 they had
a political crisis marked by the passage
of a Judiciary Reform Bill which
significantly limited the authority of
Israel's Supreme Court and prevented it
from canceling government decisions that
it deemed unreasonable so you're
probably wondering at this point when is
this video going to fulfill its title's
Promise by actually talking about the
underd discussed aspects of this
conflict well I'm going to get into that
right now I'm splitting it into two
parts so first let's go into some
differing ideas for what things like
Zionism and Israel mean within the
Jewish Community there's more diversity
than groups like The lud party would
want you to think and we'll also look
into some common Concepts used to
discuss what's happening in Israel today
namely the ideas of settler colonialism
and apartheid I didn't really develop a
political Consciousness like most people
until I was a teen I remember remember
the debate around the Iraq War Happening
by 2005 2006 I had started thinking more
critically about the world and what was
going on in it and I knew I didn't like
Bush and the neocons and the Iraq War
was a bad idea and and through that was
really how I started
questioning the presuppositions I was
taught about
Israel and that really came to the for
during Israel
invasion of Lebanon in 2006 right that
they went to war with Hezbollah over I
believe a month or
two and Destroy large parts of of
Southern Lebanon most of the casualties
were civilians and I was taught that
Israel does its utmost to evacuate the
same talking points you're hearing now
even though it's so
obviously the uh in an inversion of
reality but you know they Dro leaflet
tell people to flee uh before they're
bombing which is true but they're also
bombing people where they fled uh
sometimes and um I I I just remembered
seeing how high that civilian casualty
rate was and in sort of the the
disparity uh between Israeli and
Lebanese deaths really made me wonder
like this is the most modern Hightech
military in the world I always boast
about it but it can't manage to like
precisely Target these Hezbollah
militants I thought that was strange so
I started reading Chomsky and his
critiques I think of us Empire really
dovetailed with what I was thinking at
time in the way he sort of criticized
Israel as like an instrument of American
power really I I think put things into
perspective uh for me so one of the
terms you probably heard bouncing around
social media a whole lot right now idea
of Zionism references to zionists and
you know Zion and the Matrix or whatever
so I mentioned earlier very briefly that
Zionism is the idea of the need for a
Jewish State not only is Zionism not a
monolith there are various concepts of
what Zionism could be but it's not even
a unanimously popular thing within the
Jewish community so the reason it's
important to talk about Zionism and the
diversity within it is because Israel
and its actions and the Jewish faith are
two different things some people trying
to play cover for the brutal acts that
Israel's doing upon the Palestinian
people will try to say that you have to
associate Israel with the entirety of
Judaism and that is an unfair and
honestly kind of sacrilegious idea there
are diverse Jewish perspectives on
Israel's creation and the things that it
does let's learn a little bit about what
the Zionist movement actually is it
started as a historical and ideological
movement that was again trying to make a
Jewish homeland in Palestine today
zionists believe that Judaism is both a
nationality and a religion and that Jews
deserve their own state in their
ancestral Homeland similar to other
nationalities in 1897 Theodore herel
established the world Zionist
organization launching a movement to
secure their National home through
Public Law Zionism was one of many ideas
that emerged in the late 19th and early
20th century marked by a significant
diversity in Jewish thought known as the
hasala or Jewish Enlightenment it's
rooted in historical ties and religious
Traditions that do link Jewish people to
the land of Israel known as Zion and
despite being dispersed throughout
history Jews have long maintained a
strong connection with the land of
Israel through religious practices and
prayers multiple strains of Zionism
developed in this period each with
different perspectives on the nature of
the Jewish people's relationship with
the land of Israel and what exactly a
Jewish State should look like I'll go
through a few of them the first is
religious Zionism religious Zionism is
the belief that the land of Israel was
promised to the ancient Israelites by
God and that modern Jews must possess
and defend the lands in ways that align
with the torah's standards of Justice
the key figure in religious Zionism was
a person by the name of Rabbi Abraham
Isaac cook who argued that secular
zionists were unknowingly bringing about
the Messianic age and that all Jews
should support Zionism while recognizing
its religious significance there's also
secular Zionism this is the idea of a
response to the quote Jewish Problem of
anti-Semitism and Outsider status in
Europe I.E a response to the rising
anti-Semitism going on on the European
continent secular zionists believed that
the solution to this problem was the
establishment of a national home secular
Zionism is an idea that came from the
Rise of Nations in the late 19th century
that Jews also deserved a nation that
they could use to protect protect
themselves and their people again going
to Palestine Theodore hle the
intellectual father of Zionism is often
associated with the founding of this
particular strain of thought now there
are more than just religious and secular
zionists for example there are cultural
zionists which is often attributed to a
person named Ahad haam AKA Ashura
Ginsburg who called for the making of a
spiritual and Cultural Center for Jewish
people in Palestine not necessarily a
Jewish state but it's just an
encouragement of a mass movement of Jews
to Israel almost like a mass pilgrimage
back to the Holy Land so this idea of
Zionism calls more for Jews to focus on
things like sharing a language and
embracing a tighter Collective culture
there's also socialist Zionism which
blends elements of Zionism and socialism
and operates on the premise that the
challenges faced by Jews in the diaspora
could would persist if they were
unresolved
and instead it advocates for a mass
immigration of Jews to a single
territorial base aiming to establish a
classless Jewish Society now the more
modern one would be revisionist Zionism
Zev jeepa insky founded this perspective
and it Advocates a Zionism that's a lot
more militant and calls for the
establishment of a Jewish state that
that is expansionary to all of ancient
Israelite land he called for the
encouragement of mass Jewish immigration
to facilitate this expansion eventually
revisionists accepted that Jordan should
exist but now tries to seek permanent
Israeli control between the
Mediterranean Sea and the Jordan River
this drain of Zionism is the most
expansionist most nationalist and most
just kick them out kill them ethnic
cleanse who cares whatever we need to do
to expand the country it's the one that
Netanyahu subscribes to but also Zionism
isn't necessarily A unanimously loved
idea within Jewish thought there were
and to this day continue to be prominent
Jewish voices that oppose the idea of
Zionism I'm just going to give you a few
examples one would be diaspora
nationalism which was championed by
groups like The autonomists they had
different ideas for how to deal with the
issues of rising anti-Semitism and
Jewish life in Europe it focused more on
establishing the rights and cultural
autonomy of Jews but in the places they
already lived rather than advocating for
a separate State I.E they wanted more
Independence and more autonomy creating
enclaves within the areas that they were
already living many reform or secular
Jews opposed Zionism at the time of its
rise they were often relatively close
and assimilated with the other citizens
of their countries and they felt a
little uncomfortable with the idea of
privileging their Judaism over other
forms of their cultural and National
identities they also thought that
Zionism would lead to people accusing
Jews of having dual loyalty and
hindering their attempts to join and be
part of mainstream culture now I
mentioned that there were Zionist
socialists however there were also
socialist anti-zionists comprised mainly
of Jewish workers who opposed the idea
of colonizing Palestine in many ways
they saw commonality with their
Palestinian worker allies socialist Jews
rejected the idea of Zionism because
their goal was to fight for a just
society that transcended these states
made from National identities and
instead wanted to have a greater
classless society at the time of
zionism's Rise many Orthodox Jews also
rejected the idea they believe that the
Exile of Jews from the promised land was
divine punishment for their infidelity
to the Torah and they held that the
creation of a Jewish State before the
appearance of the Messiah was a sin they
also did not like the idea because early
Zionism was associated with secularism
and many Orthodox Jews in this period
believed that only the Messiah could
restore the Jewish people to the land of
Israel in the modern day you have groups
like Jewish voices for peace which was
founded in 1996 and is a jewish-led
organization that unequivocally opposes
Zionism viewing it as a counter to the
ideals of Justice equality and freedom
that so core to their religion they
argue that Zionism is a false and failed
answer to the real issue that Jews face
such as European anti-Semitism and on
top of that there are also many Jewish
anti-zionists around the world even a
tiny amount of them in Israel during the
massive democracy protest in Israel
there was always the anti-apartheid
block of dozens or maybe even hundreds
of activists demanding peaceful
coexistence with their Palestinian
neighbors Jewish advocacy organizations
are constantly quot in media as um
Authority on like Rising hate crimes and
anti-Semitism are um vociferously
Zionist the sers own Jewish farers uh
Ben brith Friends of the Simon wise
andth center right I I I mean these
groups work over time to conflate
Judaism with Israel and by extension its
founding ideology political Zionism that
that suggests there needs to be a uh
Jewish state
in uh historic Palestine it's really
frustrating because they claim to speak
on behalf of all Jews and you read the
media oh the Jewish Community here in
Edmonton I mean the Jewish Federation of
Edmonton are I I mean they're totally
just conservative mouthpieces right like
that um I mean Edmonton's mayor right
after October 7th I thought issued a a
thoughtful statement which is what I
think a municipal leader should have
been saying at that time in that we have
uh Jewish edmontonians we have
Palestinian edmontonians and I care
about both of them and hope their fam
stay safe and the Jewish Federation of
Edmonton went
ballistic they were saying you're
equating Israel's self-defense with
Hamas
terrorism and and they called his
statement disgusting just really overthe
toop stuff that's frankly quite
embarrassing as as a Jewish person who
who doesn't uh endorse that worldview
and the second you're at all critical of
Israel publicly you're just banished
from all these like mainstream Jewish
institutions and when you see Israel uh
acting on the world stage as it does
preparing to represent all Jewish people
and doing what they're doing for the
benefit of Jews that is also uh
incredibly embarrassing and appalling
and um but what has this time given me a
lot of Hope and comfort and
and pride is seeing all these Jewish
organizations now on the front lines
advocating for Palestinian human rights
Jewish voice for peace in the states uh
independent Jewish voices here in Canada
which I'm a member of uh if not now and
uh other other groups like the um United
Jewish people's order and say yeah we're
Jews and we're against this place uh
support for the Palestinian cause in the
context of Jewish values of being kind
to your neighbors and building a better
world and Seeking Justice now in the
years since Israel has come into
existence there's also been a wide
variety of perspectives as to what
Israel means whether it's a good thing
and what to do about the various
conflicts that it's created the Zionist
movement did achieve its goal by
establishing the state of Israel in
1948 and Israel has become a center of
Jewish identity and culture for millions
of Jews around the world Israel is a
Sovereign Nation with a predominantly
Jewish population and that's quite a
profound thing it's often referred to as
a Jewish state but still it actually
doesn't have an official state religion
which leads to some uh tension because
the state's definition of Jewish creates
a a conflict between the state and
religious law but Jewish perspectives on
Israel vary widely with differences
often aligning with levels of
religiosity I apologize already for my
Hebrew but for example nearly all kedim
Ultra Orthodox Jews and daim religious
Jews believe that God gave Israel to the
Jewish people at the same time far fewer
secular hilon Jews hold this view in the
United States caring about Israel is
considered either an essential or
substantial part of just being Jewish
but there's still a wide range of
opinions about the Israeli government
and its policies Orthodox Jews in the US
are more likely than other Jewish
denominations to feel very attached to
Israel and view its leadership POS
positively the relationship with Judaism
as a religion differs between Israeli
Jews and American Jews while nearly all
Israeli Jews identify as Jewish by
religion a significant percentage of
American Jews identify as Jewish by
ancestry or culture rather than by faith
Jewish Americans have wildly different
views on Israel uh which tend to break
across different factions like
denominations uh political parties even
age groups for example many younger Jews
and those involved with Progressive
movements often have very different
views from older Generations or more
conservative segments of the same
Community now you've probably also heard
of two different terms floating around
on the internet in association with what
Israel is doing in Palestine settler
colonialism and AAR
and I'm going to go into settler
colonialism first settler colonialism in
the historical sense is a very specific
type of colonialism so for example you
might have a more classic version of
colonialism like what happened in India
where you have a small British Elite
typically ruling over something that
resembles the old institutional orders
just placing themselves on the top of
the height hierarchy and using their
power over a mass population which they
are minority rulers of as a way to
extract economic resources brutally
violently horrifically this defines much
of the last few hundred years of History
settler colonialism is distinct settler
colonialism is what Canada is it's what
America is it's what Australia is it
involves instead of merely using the
indigenous popul
to gain resources it's about replacing
the indigenous population with invasive
settler societies over time these
invasive settler colonies will develop
their own unique identities and
eventually gain sovereignty this process
is defined by oppressive acts like
genocide and mass displacement with an
attempt to replace or displace the
indigenous population and replace them
with new settlers often times they then
then assert a whole form of new state
sovereignty over the land and continue
the process you see this in Canada with
our constant ignoring or taking a way of
indigenous sovereignty to Sate our
extreme sexual attraction to oil
pipelines the United States has often
disregarded the sovereignty of its
indigenous people and has had no issues
with again taking more and more
indigenous territory to build more and
more resource extraction capacity
however there has also o been some
victory in at least those two countries
because of the landback movement
Australia has this exact same problem
South Africa has the same problem it's
relevant because understanding conflicts
in places like Argentina Kenya and
Israel you need to understand settler
colonialism it's a process and and it's
a thing that makes Global indigenous
movements have a common purpose in their
struggle to keep themselves alive
because they know that if they lose this
conflict it means the end of their
entire existence and the Israeli attempt
to expand into Palestine has been
compared to settler colonialism Scholars
and activists draw parallels between the
experiences of Palestinians and those of
indigenous populations displaced by
other settler colonial projects one of
those connections being made by the
Assembly of First Nations of Canada
building these illegal settlements that
then displace the indigenous people's
land that they are on is is very very
very similar to the expansion of
colonies in a more widely recognized
settler Colonial context now I'd be
remiss in mentioning that there are some
points of Distinction some argue that
Israel doesn't fit the model of settler
colonialism because there's no mother
country that Jewish settlers in
Palestine come from instead of it being
a straight up settler Colonial situation
it might be more conductive to say that
it is two people with nowhere else to go
trying to Duke it out but this uh this
Rings really Hollow with me when you see
like a Palestinian olive oil farm that
that family had owned for Generations
get evicted from that farm so that
settlers can demolish their house and
build a retirement home for a couple
from Philadelphia Zionism is a secular
colonialist movement there's this in
this talking point going around that
this was actually an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory drafted
by the Soviet Union in the
1960s whereas before that no one had
ever called Israel a settler colonial
state and that I mean you just look at
the historical record and that's totally
fictitious uh Theodore Herzel uh wrote a
letter to cesil rhods trying to obtain
his support for the Zionist project
telling him that you're I I have this
project that I think you're going to be
really excited about because it's
something Colonial right he made no
secret of Zev
jabotinsky who was the pioneer of the
more
right-wing strand of Zionist thought
that's associated with today's Lee coup
party he was also quite open and
critizing the the sort of more socialist
and labor zionists who just thought ah
the Palestinians they'll get over it
like we're coming and we're going to
build a Jewish State here and they're
going to see how great it is and they'll
be fine with either moving elsewhere or
living as second class citizens and
jabotinsky was like no they're not
they're they not because we're
colonizing them and he's like look
everywhere in the world he explicitly
compared Palestinians to the cuu in the
Americas and the Aztec in in the
Americas and said whenever you see
people getting colonized they're going
to fight you and so in his obviously he
wasn't saying we shouldn't do this it's
just that we need to prepare for war and
to create what you called an iron wall
that shows the indigenous population
that we're here to stay and there's
nothing you can do about it and then we
can reach an agreement that's on like
our terms another handy comparison we
would be comparing what's happening in
Gaza and the West Bank to what happened
in South Africa under the apartheid
regime Scholars historians and
commentators hotly debate this
comparison the term apartheid originally
described the system of
institutionalized racial segregation in
South Africa which lasted from 1948 to
1994 some human rights organizations
legal experts and individuals have used
the term apartheid to describe how
Israel has treated Palestinians in the
last few decades prominent figures and
organizations such as President Jimmy
Carter Archbishop Desmond Tutu former
speaker of the knesset which is Israel's
governing body Abraham Berg along with
groups like Amnesty International Human
Rights Watch and Israeli human rights
organizations like balem they have all
argued that Israel has implemented a
regime involving settler colonialism
apartheid and occupation of Palestinian
people and there are many similarities
to South African apartheid Force
displacement division of the colonized
into different groups with different
sets of Rights severe restriction on
movement and violent suppression of
resistance analysts base the comparison
on perceived similarities which as you
know include the same element you see
things like the fact that Israel limits
where Palestinians can go like the ID
cards that South Africans had to have
there are separate Road networks for
Palestinians and their security system
applies systematic racial oppression and
Israel openly practices racial profiling
Palestinians enjoy way fewer rights and
non-white citizens of Israel
Palestinians in the West Bank also face
segregation systematic discrimination
and often very violent repression and
there's also settler colonialism
happening in the sense that about half
of the West Bank's land has been stolen
and you know if this regime just keeps
going the expansion will eventually just
make all of the West Bank part of the
Israeli State daily life for
Palestinians in the West Bank is made
unpredictable because of the constant
and arbitrary changing of the rules now
I I would argue that it's actually an
excellent comparison and a significant
one because a mix of indigenous
resistance and global pressure was what
brought down the apartheid regime in
South Africa so calling it apartheid
means that we can talk about reigniting
these campaigns and putting an end to
the regime that's happening in Israel
but they're also not completely
identical and I'm going to be The
Annoying historian who needs to ensure
that everything is precise I fact check
the script three times so let's
also talk about how they're different
for example South Africa and apartheid
had a regime of something called Petty
apartheid Petty apartheid was the system
of laws that involve things like
segregating public facilities or social
events uh it involved the prohibition on
mixed marriages things like that it's
also just the fact that apartheid might
be too small a term to refer to what's
going on in Palestine because it doesn't
Encompass the larger aspects like the
military occupation and stealing of land
however I think calling it apartheid is
powerful because it has a lot of similar
processes it's an injustice in the same
way and much of the Western World
ignores it in the same way most
importantly though it's something we can
resist and ultimately defeat in the same
way okay now let's go into the second
part of this we're going to go deeper
and look into some less discussed
aspects of this conflict that are
important for understanding it with a
complete perspective the first is that
this is not a morally equal conflict
you'll probably see in the media or in
the ways that people talk about Israel
that this is a both sides type situation
uh you could just have a drinking game
for any Israel video you watch and just
count how many times people say say both
sides just don't watch Vox cuz you'll
die uh they'll say one side is
just as bad or just as powerful as the
other and that the morality of this is
either even-handed or that the
Palestinians are straight up the bad
guys the vital thing that you have to
know though is that through all of this
one side has continuously and
perpetually had more power and committed
far more violations of international law
than the other the Israeli Palestinian
conflict is fined by its significant
power imbalance and gross violations of
international law because Israel has a
vastly more powerful military political
and economic capacity Israel holds
virtually all the power both regionally
and internationally and it is a
significant challenge for opposing the
regime Palestinians are always fighting
asymmetrically they're always fighting
with their arm tied behind their back
because they're always dealing with this
massive power imbalance Israel has one
of the world's most modernized
militaries it has a secret but not super
secret nuclear Arsenal it allocates a
huge part of its budget to Defense
Forces Palestine doesn't have a
recognized State they have Observer
status in the United Nations and that's
it they don't have a regular army which
leaves them with way fewer resources to
defend themselves Israeli forces have
reported to kill and injure Palestinian
civilians unlawfully and humongous
numbers their settlement policy clearly
violates preemptory Norms of
international law which are obligations
that all states must enforce
international law is the law that
governs relations and conduct between
sovereign states International
organizations and individuals it covers
many issues including trade human rights
diplomacy envir enironmental
preservation it's overseen by groups
like The World Trade Organization or the
United Nations international law aims to
promote peace and order but it still
relies on participating Nations consent
and no overarching body enforces it
there's also the concept of Human Rights
we should also talk about the concept of
Human Rights the idea that there are
rights that are inherent to all human
individuals irrespective of their ality
what their residence is what their sex
is etc etc they're supposed to be
Universal inalienable interdependent and
indivisible
non-discrimination participation and
accountability so through that lens of
international law and the preservation
of Human Rights we have many many many
cases of Israel blatantly violating
internal interational law and denying
Palestinians their human rights the
international criminal court holding
jurisdiction over war crimes and
Palestine opened an investigation in
2021 into possible war crimes committed
in the territory the UN Human Rights
Council has had reasonable grounds many
times to conclude that Israeli
occupation of Palestinian territory is
unlawful under international law and
many of Israel's actions are
constitutive of illegal occupation
researchers have documented allegations
of apartheid and persecution against
Palestinians by Israeli officials which
if presented to the international
criminal court could constitute crimes
against humanity at the same time
Palestinian armed groups are accused of
war crimes themselves such as targeting
civilians or using human Shields however
ever that one that human shield claim
never ever seems to pan out and gets
consistently debunked however bad the
scale and impact of Palestinian war
crimes are not even in the same
universe as the capacities of the IDF
and on that note Israel has a long
history of committing war crimes without
any consequences they have racked up
many condemnations over the years from
the United Nations Amnesty International
has documented instances of Israeli
attacks in Gaza that result in Mass
civilian casualty other International
bodies including the international
criminal court and the independent
International Commission of inquiry have
also investigated allegations of war
crimes but which crimes have they broken
specifically Israel's policy of settling
civilians in occupied Palestinian
territory is considered a violation of
the Fourth Geneva Convention and
International law furthermore and this
is very appropo of our current moment
Israel has been accused of engaging in
Collective punishment the ongoing
settlement and occupation of Palestinian
territories have created a humanitarian
crisis that has been criticized as a
form of collective punishment the
blockade of Gaza by Israel has been
criticized as a form of collective
punishment all of this Collective
punishment is also a war crime and a
violation of international law they've
also been accused of using prohibited
weapons such as white phosphorus in
densely populated areas of Gaza which
also goes against International
humanitarian law because of the
indiscriminate because of the
indiscriminate suffering it causes other
violations of international law
include massive land seizures unlawful
killings serious injuries forcible
transfers restrictions on freedom of
movement movement and the denial of
nationality the United Nations has
consistently viewed Israel's settlements
and activities in the occupied
territories as illegal and has
criticized Israel for failing to
investigate their violations and crimes
again under international law adequately
they've gotten away with this and they
have not had any repercussions or
Consequences because the United States
has the support of many key Western
allies their economic and military power
as well as having a permanent Security
Council veto basically stalls any
opportunity to intervene when Israel
commits these acts so the ongoing
conflict and lack of resolution create a
cycle of violence and human rights
concern you sometimes also hear that
this is some sort of intractable
conflict that has been going on for
thousands of years and there's going to
be no end in it that there's no point in
a peace or an attempt at peace from any
side but there has been attempts many
times to make peace between Palestine
and Israel and some have come
astonishingly close but they've been
hindered by sabotage the peace process
began earnestly in the 1970s it led to
discussions with different parties
proposals and attempts to find peace
terms that both could agree on as I
mentioned earlier the Oslo Accords were
one of the most significant attempts at
a peace process in those Israel did
recognize the PLO as a representative of
the Palestinians and the PLO renounced
terrorism and recognized Israel's right
to exist in peace but it has been marred
by sabotage this recent attack in 2023
Hamas was accused of sabotaging an
imminent piece by launching an attack
that derailed a new peace process
starting to come underway called the
Abraham Accords the Israelis have also
been accused of undermining the peace
process by building all of these
settlements for decades without stopping
often times the expansion of these
settlements are timed to coincide with
progress in the peace negotiations
furthermore in an even larger sense
Israel has done stuff like supporting
the Islamic charity that became Hamas in
the 1970s and ' 80s as a means of trying
to weaken these secular nationalist
forces and build up their West Bank
settlements Netanyahu even bolstered
hamas's rule in recent years by
facilitating qari funding to them the
longer Hamas stays in power Israel can
turn Hamas into an inhuman nameless
motivation monster that can justify
further and more violent actions against
Palestinians and many times when a peace
process happens there's no understanding
of the inherent power dynamics often
they offer deals that weaken Palestinian
leaders and undermine their institutions
while fueling Israeli expansionism this
removes pressure on the stronger party
and increases pressure on the weaker
party which is a complete reversal of
the role that a mediator should provide
you also often hear that the ultimate
solution that will make everybody happy
is the two-state solution the idea of
going back and uh proposing an
independent Palestinian State just like
the British wanted to do that would
exist alongside Israel and it's widely
been seen as the solution for many years
the problem is that the viability of
this solution is getting increasingly
called into question there have been
many factors that called this into
question but things like the fact that
now for decades Israel has been again
illegally expanding into the West Bank
and that there's this massive power
imbalance between the two countries and
just no political will to separate these
countries some see it as the best
solution for self-determination but
years of illegal settlement have
drastically changed the demographics on
the West Bank something you can't just
undo overnight but there are
alternatives and this one might not be
the best option the one-state solution
might be an alternative that say Tristan
might be more interested in which
proposes a single secular state that
ensures equal rights for Israeli Jews
and Palestinian Arabs it's a way to
avoid the challenges of separating
Israelis and Palestinians still many
Israelis see it unfavorably as it would
change the character of the state but
the idea of a multifaith democracy
undermining one of the core countries to
which I say good the country's core
ideas right now have killed thousands
and thousands of people still one of the
most important things that we need to
happen is some aspect of Truth and
Reconciliation any attempt to end this
conflict that doesn't end in some kind
of Truth and Reconciliation peace
process is just going to be a setup for
even more wars in the future and a
two-state solution that doesn't address
the inherent inequalities and resources
in power is just going to result in
Palestine being one of the most
impoverished countries on Earth and
having no allies the last thing you need
to be told is you need a clear picture
of what's Happening media portrayals of
the conflict have significantly impacted
the understanding of what's going on
media bias and selective framing of
events can drastically shape public
perception certain words being used to
describe events that influence how you
interpret things language in reporting a
story can frame and significantly change
how people see things choice of words
and historical details are important the
Israeli perspective has historically
dominated policy in the western press
Western media is is fairly rightly
accused of having a significant bias in
favor of Israel portraying it as
equivalent or engaging in a cycle of
violence instead of it being a very
one-sided Affair there's also an
overreliance on talking about the
victimhood of the Israeli side through
personal stories while at the same time
Palestinian casualties are reduced to
Mere contextless numbers though this has
started to change somewhat social media
has given more prominence to the pro
Palestinian voices and their perspective
although at the same time social media
has become a battlefield of information
Warfare about the conflict content
posted by Palestinians and their
supporters on social media is often
censored because they're showing the
truth which often is you know gory and
bloody but also they've been bans or
they're just too under attack to
regularly post on the internet and
there's been a significant presence of
disinformation on both sides but Israel
has a well-developed strategy of
disinformation for committing narrative
Warfare called hbar hbar that Loosely
translates to explaining in Hebrew is a
program with a primary objective to
articulate and justify Israel's actions
and policies particularly in the context
of the Israeli Palestinian conflict this
strategy is not limited to only
presenting information it extends to
shaping narratives in a way that favors
Israel perspective on geopolitical
issues and it is on Full blast
during this ethnic cleansing campaign of
the past few months not to mention
they're getting a bunch of help from
India because India has this like
radically
anti-muslim uh fake news machine that
has decided to also help out Israel but
I don't think Israel was behind that or
anything it's just another way that they
have their thumb on the scale of what
you're seeing in the realm of social
media hbar involves the dissemination of
both information and disinformation
aimed at reinforcing Israel's stance on
various issues tactics employed under
this strategy include a mix of botn Nets
and also human operated accounts these
accounts spread
pro-government narratives they counter
opposition views and actively work to
suppress narratives that are critical of
Israel the content created and
disseminated can range from strategic
dis information campaigns to more uh
subtle approaches like trolling
amplifying favorable narratives and and
employing data-driven strategies to
influence public opinion the hosb
strategy is not a standalone operation
it represents a public private
partnership uh where the state apparatus
leads the effort but it supported by a
network of committed volunteers this
coordinated approach in assures that the
strategy is multifaceted and well suited
for the digital age enabling it to adapt
to an evolving landscape of online media
and communication they target a wide
range of audiences including diplomats
politicians and the general public
hospira operates through various
channels not limited to just social
media it leverages mass media and other
forms of communication these are often
released and promoted directly by the
Israeli state or its supporters to
maximize reach and impact Palestine
typically has Whoever has survived to
point their camera phone at the Carnage
laid upon them by the IDF all that then
brings us to what's happening right now
in Gaza it All Began on October 7th with
a surprise attack by Hamas and other
militant groups based in Gaza they
launched thousands of rockets into
Israel and infiltrated Border army bases
and an outdoor music F that resulted in
the deaths of hundreds of Israelis and
the Abduction of
270 hostages it was the deadliest attack
on Israel since its founding and
immediately after this happened the
world held its breath expecting Israel's
retaliation with allegations that they
had plans for essentially ethnically
cleansing the entirety of Gaza on
October 9th Israel ordered a quote
Complete Siege of the Gaza Strip stating
that no electricity no food no water and
no fuel would be allowed into it the
Israeli military aimed to quote
completely destroy the government and
infrastructure of Hamas the the military
then began to pounded Gaza with air
strikes and seemed to have preparations
for a ground Invasion on October 10th
Israeli troops regained control of towns
near the Gaza Strip on October 13th
Israel instructed residents of Gaza City
where more than 1 million of gaza's 2.3
million people live and told them to
evacuate and move South but Gaza
remained closed and residents reported
that they had nowhere to go on October
28th prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
announced that Israel's forces had begun
the second phase of the war he warned
that Israelis should expect a long and
hard military campaign on the 25th Hamas
Fighters released the first wave of 24
hostages including Israeli women and
children with more set to be freed later
still Israel has still completely cut
off gaza's power water and fuel it has
at this point done an ethnic cleansing
campaign of the entirety of Northern
Gaza people are reported to be starving
to be dying of thirst and the IDF has
penned the 2 million plus people into
Southern Gaza
turning it into now the most densely
populated place on the planet Earth no
food no water no power no medical
supplies no medicine they're they've
destroyed all but one hospital as of now
this ongoing conflict has resulted in
the deaths of over
23,000 Palestinians over 7,000 of them
are children one of the things that
doesn't make it past is that gaza's like
50% children it's also reported that
15,000 children have been wounded some
of these including multiple amputations
and disfiguring stars for life and we
haven't even seen all the other
atrocities during this conflict
including the strike on the courtyard of
the AL AI Hospital in Gaza City by
Israel which resulted in the deaths of
471 People Israel and the US assert that
this was done by an errant Islamic Jihad
rocket but this isn't even the first
time Israel is bombed a hospital and
it's not even the first time that Israel
has used this specific lie to cover for
bombing a hospital and the chief
evidence put forward to say that that
they bombed themselves is a video one
that has a lot of discrepancies and when
the New York Times who published it were
asked where this Source came from they
say that it originated from Israeli
sources not the US RZ seagull a
holocaust and genocide St scholar
described what Israel is doing in Gaza
as a quote textbook case of genocide and
there are some signs that Israel intends
to expel the entirety of the population
of Gaza to other countries a complete
and total ethnic cleansing of this land
that they have lived on for some of them
centuries Millennia even and the
potential for this to spill into a
greater conflict is high we've already
seen some of that with what's happening
in Yemen with the houthis but there also
could be involvement from Iran or who
knows what else the region has a lot of
tension and interconnection that if
something goes sideways could lead to a
deadly Regional War the US has since
focused on criticizing politicians in
the US for the crime of criticizing
Israel for what it's doing specifically
calling out politicians like Ayanna
Presley Cory Bush and Rashida TB who by
the way is Palestinian herself calling
them repugnant and disgraceful for
opposing the ethnic cleansing of her own
people and more recently on the
international stage South Africa has
filed a case against Israel on December
29th keep in mind these things could
change drastically because this is stuff
currently happening on December 29th on
December 29th South Africa brought a
significant International legal action
against Israel filing a case at the
international court of justice accusing
Israel of committing genocide in Gaza
the suit is grounded in the 1948
genocide convention which both South
Africa and Israel are signatories to
South Africa's accusation focuses on the
claim that Israel's military actions in
Gaza have resulted in the deaths of over
23,000 people including near nearly
10,000 children South Africa contends
that these deaths along with Israel's
destruction of Health Services leading
to the prevention of Palestinian births
amount to genocidal acts the suit
further details Israel's failure to
provide humanitarian assistance to Gaza
during the war essential supplies like
food water medicine Fuel and shelter
things they openly said they were doing
also South Africa cites the the
sustained bombing campaign by Israel as
devastating much of Gaza forcing the
evacuation of 1.9 million Palestinians
of 2.3 million by the way South Africa
has also urged the icj to take immediate
action to prevent Israel from committing
further acts of genocide arguing for
provisional measurements to protect the
rights of Palestinian people under the
genocide convention which they claim are
being
continuously violated Israel has
responded by criticizing South Africa
for starting the case in the first place
and has basically just said that it
doesn't even acknowledge the
jurisdiction of the ICC which by the way
stunning argument uh the ICC is also
independently investigating similar
atrocities in Gaza and the West Bank at
the time I'm recording this the icj has
had two days of public hearings and in
them South Africa Africa has made its
case Israel tried to make its defense
but the final ruling could take years
the court might issue a decision for an
interim measure which could address the
ongoing bombardment of Gaza within weeks
their decisions are legally binding and
final and there's no option for appeal
but still their ability to enforce these
decisions is limited it's also important
to point out that there is a small
minority of Israeli voices calling for
restraint and Reconciliation several
individuals have identified themselves
as opposing the government's approach
and advocating for peace and dialogue
one such group is standing together
standing together is a Grassroots
organization in Israel that was founded
in late 2015 and has grown to become the
largest Arab Jewish Grassroots movement
in the country the organization's Vision
revolves around promoting peace equality
and social and climate Justice they
Envision a society where Palestinians
and Arabs choose peace Justice and
interdependence the recent attack has
also spawned from its seething birthing
chamber a wave of social media
propaganda and disinformation campaigns
social media algorithms exacerbate
propaganda as we've seen many many times
and promote inflammatory claims it's
really bad timing that this happened at
a time where Twitter has basically lost
all guard rail for example the reports
of babies being beheaded at kafar aak
kabut on October 7th are completely
unverified they don't seem to have any
basis in reality but they spread all
over social media anyway this is this
disinformation got all the way to the
president a pretty straightforward
comparison would be the fabricated
claims that the US put forward about
Iraqi forces when they went into Kuwait
in 1990 about Kuwaiti babies being
killed we've seen lots of propaganda
from different groups for example
Netanyahu and the Israeli defense
minister Gant have actively used
dehumanizing rhetoric towards
Palestinians similar to the 1982
invasion of Lebanon and the Sabra and
catella Massacre there have been big
instances of backlash against public
figures for the crime of expressing
empathy towards Palestinians but also in
the West Bank where there's not supposed
to be violence happening we have also
seen an escalation of Israeli violence
since October 7th the people who oppose
Israeli expansions of settlements have
experienced increased attacks
intimidation and destruction of villages
even shootings over 850 Palestinians
including 13 communities have been
displaced since October 7th and the
government plans to arm militias in the
West Bank with 10,000 assault rifles
there's no real sign that it any point
in the future the us is going to make
Israel's military accountable for
anything including these settler attacks
I I woke up it was Saturday morning I I
got like a news alert saying that Hamas
had invaded Southern Israel and took
over a military post and I was of course
when you occupy people for 75 years and
uh dehumanize them I mean obviously
they're going to fight back and I mean
if they're just taking over military
posts they have a right to resist under
international law right that isn't
absolute it's not anything goes but that
would include attacking military
installations um and and I think it was
around that time that you saw a lot of
posts on social media and stupid
comments at at rallies that were really
dragged out proportion celebrating this
th this attack before people really knew
like the quite horrific nature of what
occurred on on October 7th but then as
details keep coming kept coming out the
casualty figure kept getting higher it
was just like oh wow that's a lot of
people getting killed and now everyone
who's paid attention to this issue knew
exactly what was going to happen next
because it's Israel's only ever response
to Palestinian violence against Israel
it's to meet out even greater violence
against the pal Indians uh so they know
their place but I remember for that
first week it it was definitely a shock
to see how for about a week the the
Israeli uh casualty count was higher
than the palestin casualty count right
that's never been the case in in our
lifetimes and I don't since the
Inception of the state of Israel right
and there were Pro Palestinian rties
everywhere that were being smeared by
politicians across
Spectrum as being these celebrations of
Hamas violence and I mean I do think
that there was an element of that from
some people who attended these protests
but no the the the general thrust of
these protests were like oh like
Israel's going to launch its worst ever
attack on Gaza right I I mean a few days
in uh their defense minister and
announces that they're cutting off water
fuel food
electricity uh we're fighting Human
animals and we need to talk
accordingly and I think that really set
the stage for the horrors we've
witnessed the the the past few months
but even I remember that first weekend
or week after October 7th there was a
palestin rally in Edmonton and and
normally you know and pass attacks
against Gaza I would go out and be on
the streets uh you know protesting uh
against Israeli uh aggression but this
time that that first rally it just
didn't feel right to me I mean I have
family in
Israel right I I like them I think
they're good people I think that they're
part of an unjust system that they've
been indoctrinated into as I have in a
different way but I you know I certainly
don't wish them harm friends family
friends of mine uh had a niece who was
thought to have been kidnapped uh but it
later came out was killed on October 7th
presumably by Hamas um though there were
some people who were killed by uh
shelling from uh Israeli forces it's
becoming increasingly clear though they
would still be a minority of the people
killed on October 7th and so I just sat
that one out but then again as it
entered the second week it was like okay
they're doing exactly what everyone
who's been paying attention knew they
were going to do that and of course it
was like Hey I'm going to take to the
streets with everyone else and many
other Jewish people uh were as well I uh
saw a couple people um at at that first
rally I went to from my synagogue here
in Edmonton which I I mean I I'm not
that type of Jew that goes to sanog
regularly it's more like on the on the
high holidays right but the high
holidays were recently and I just met
them at my synagogue and there they were
uh protesting for justice for
Palestinians but I think most Jewish
people did were feeling very conflicted
at least for that first week or two if
not still and and and cuz I mean that's
a lot of people killed right the
horrible attacks on October 7th were the
result of this mentality that you can
perpetually occupy people without
cost but that resistance in whatever
form it takes is inevitable inevitable
not justifiable some resistance is
justifiable but not not all as you can
guess this has not been an easy video to
make I knew I had to say something when
things broke out last October still I
obviously can't say anything important
without apparently making an hour plus
worth of content about it I knew that
silence was not something I could bring
myself to do this moment is when we are
all OB oated to put pressure on anyone
we can to make the change that needs to
happen and on a greater scale I do hope
that if the International Community
could put enough pressure on Israel we
could see a legitimate move if they
could if Israel could be held
accountable for its action there is a
path forward I often think about alland
delus a period from the 8th to the 15th
century in Spain a golden age for Spain
really under these Muslim rulers
obviously this is glossing over some of
the fiddly bits but Jews were generally
accepted in society and their religious
cultural and economic life Forest they
participated in all sectors of the
economy and weren't prohibited from
doing any trades which is a very
different story in the rest of Christian
Europe some of the figures you might
remember from this period are people
like mades who was an amazing scholar of
the Torah a doctor a philosopher an
astronomer
and a rabbi then when the Christians
took over the Spanish Inquisition came
for Muslims and Jews alike the Jews who
escaped from the Spanish Inquisition
found themselves in the Ottoman Empire
another Muslim ruler this Empire needed
the skills and knowledge of the Jewish
people and built a relationship to their
Mutual benefit during this period there
was a significant Synergy in religious
thought and philosophy all implying
heavy interconnectedness and dialogue
between Jews and Muslims all of this is
to say that Jews and Muslims don't have
this thousands of years long history of
intractable hatred and violence towards
each other and that nobody who
understands history or understands
Humanity promotes that type of thinking
you see that narrative uh pop up all the
time not just for Israel Palestine for
that issue you go back to the wars in
the Balkans too it's like oh just these
ancient hatred surges
suddenly emerging and uh yeah it's
really complicated don't think too much
about it just let Uncle Sam take care of
it right that's the function it serves
in reality right don't even think about
it it's so complicated you have to have
like a PhD in history uh in like ancient
near East history to understand it so
yeah just let let us take care of it
don't you worry where whereas I I I mean
nationalism is is a very modern uh
phenomenon right and Jewish nationalism
is no exception nor is Arab nationalism
or Palestinian nationalism and so you
don't need to go back thousands of years
to understand what's happening now in in
Gaza right you you you have to go back
about you know 150 years to to to really
understand creating the starting Point
earlier right obscures the roots of the
conflict that it's just all these
contending tribal religious loyalties
that actually have little bearing on on
our lives today and that nationalism or
colonialism is just not not even a
consideration right and it also obscures
the uh gross
asymmetry and power between Israelis and
Palestinians by being just like oh it's
just Muslims and Jews fighting cuz then
The Logical um extension of that is well
there are like 40 Islamic states in the
world why can't there be one Jewish
state right and again this this is all
these narratives serve to shift our
attention away from the actual causes
right and and essentially say there is
no cause there is no root cause it's all
subjective it's all just uh contending
histories that have always that is and
it's orientalist right talking about how
the Arab world in particular is just
unchanging in the same thing that's
happening now is the exact same thing
that happened 1500 years ago hey
everyone in 2015 I started this channel
because I wanted to make Punchy
educational videos about history but
right from the outset I found myself
drawn to the topic of conspiracy
theories in today's world r with
propaganda and misinformation my aim
with stepb back is to offer a
counternarrative addressing conspiracy
theories directly or challenging The
Narrative shaped by powerful interests I
firmly believe that understanding
history is crucial in this fight against
misinformation also on this channel I
try to talk about sensitive subjects or
cover things that wouldn't end up on a
mainstream History Channel I like to
emphasize the stories of those
marginalized and historical narratives
this includes shedding light on the
experiences of lgbtq plus individuals
indigenous peoples and Palestinian
people over the years I've received
messages from members of the groups
featured in my videos many have
expressed how meaningful these videos
have been to them I've also gotten
messages over the years from people
talking about how this work that I do
has helped them decide majors at their
universities or the subject of their
dissertation or their thesis or they
walked back from a dark political path
due to something they watched on my
channel I made this channel hoping to
make this world a better place than how
I left it and every time one of these
things happens I'm speechless honestly
I'm kind of struggling to put a sentence
together right now but this is not an
easy thing to do my videos have had
issues of being censored I've had
sponsors who've tried to change the
content of my videos I've had many
videos demonetized because they just
weren't adver iser friendly I'd make a
video talking about an important subject
but it would be one that coke wouldn't
want it stuff beside and that has had
you know hurt me business-wise but I
think it's important to do anyway and on
the topic of this video Gaza is an
unfolding issue with a lot of powerful
interest at play trying to steer The
Narrative our media ecosystem has
resulted in tons of misinformation to
Halt the ongoing violence we must exert
pressure on powerful institutions so
it's crucial we ensure the information
we consume and share about this issue is
accurate and one of the greatest
channels that I have been using for
keeping myself up to date is a channel
called tldd daily TLD drr daily is
making videos all the time about the
unfolding situation in Gaza as it
happens and the place that you can do
that best is by going to their page on
nebula while you're there nebula has
some amazing fiction content the prince
the play by Abigail Thorne is a
spectacular play that you really should
check out and also this year we're
getting two movies written and directed
by trans women Dracula's ex-girlfriend
also by Abigail but you also have
identities coming out that has John
Delany in it written and directed by
Jesse Jinder many voices of people who
are often over looked by mainstream
media have a platform on nebula that
gets them in front of lots of people who
need to hear what they have to say
nebula came along at a time when I was
fairly close to shuttering step back and
it literally save the channel if you
sign up for nebula part of your
membership goes to continue supporting
me and this channel keeping it going if
you're watching this video my guess is
that you have an appreciation for
countering dangerous propaganda and
furthering the cause of justice for
those overlooked and I'll tell you that
nebula is how I do this you know how did
Harry make a 4our video on plagiarism in
the YouTube Community if it wasn't for
something like nebula something that no
journalistic Outlet would ever give the
time of day to but I also know that
money is a thing that exists and I very
much understand that I made a recent
video on Tristan won't shut up that
shows that I really understand that
money can be tight for you so I'm going
to try and do you a solid with a little
discount if you go to my link here or if
you use my link in the right there or in
the description or if you have a QR code
scanner you can use that if you're
watching on a TV and you use that to
sign up for an annual membership you'll
get 40% off you can buy it once for a
good price you don't have to worry about
it until next year which is really great
because because I am also monthly
subscription out so sign up use the link
and you'll have a huge library of cool
stuff to watch and you'll be able to
know that you are helping get important
voices saying important messages in
front of a lot of people so thanks so
much and speaking of well researched
highquality content I think it's really
important that I mention that the reason
I wanted to make this is to get across
that there is an urgency right now a lot
of people who are watching this video
right now live in Europe America Canada
all countries that are either
rhetorically or even materially
supporting the violence that's happening
right now the ethnic cleansing campaign
that's happening right now we all need
to learn about this situation as it
really is and get involved right now
because every moment that we're not
pressuring those in power to call for a
ceasefire is being paid in human lives
so pressuring your government is super
super important right now and in the
longer term there are also things that
you can do you specifically you Jeffrey
this minute and keep that pressure going
until the whole regime comes down it's a
very simple peaceful thing that has been
unfairly maligned but what everyone can
do is help pressure regime right now and
that is called BDS BDS stands for
boycott divestment and sanctions it's an
attempt to end International support for
Israel's oppression of Palestinians and
to pressure them to comply with
international law it was founded in 2005
by individuals Omar baruti and Ramy shat
and Palestinians primarily lead it the
BDS movement aims to pressure Israel to
meet its obligations it's based on the
princip Le that Palestinians are
entitled to the same rights as the rest
of humanity with the BDS movement is
about is challenging International
support for Israeli policies that they
consider unjust like the occupation and
colonization of Palestinian land
discrimination against Palestinian
civilians in Israel and the denial of
the right of return for those refugees
it draws inspiration from the South
African an anti-apartheid movement it
involves economic and cultural boycotts
as well as Financial divestment
government sanctions and other tools
again to just pressure Israel to stop
doing all of these horrific acts so one
of the things that you can do is not buy
stuff from very specific companies or
products closely linked to Israel's
violation of international law I'll put
a link in the description of this video
to where you can check them out off the
top of my head uh Starbucks don't do
that Pepsi uh-uh Sabah humus definitely
not so to stream no but there's
plenty more the BDS movement has gained
support from various unions academic
institutions churches and Grassroots
movements worldwide it's been endorsed
by people like Archbishop Desmond Tutu
Naomi kleene Roger Waters Angela Davis
and Judith Butler and if you remember
from just a few years ago that BDS was
considered super controversial despite
it being a peaceful pressure campaign to
stop horrific abuse and those same
people who a few years ago were you know
decrying the BDS movement and saying
that it was the worst thing you could
possibly do show off their their Pikachu
surprised faces when Palestinians resort
to violent resistance and they'll show
solidarity to people in Ukraine who are
defending themselves for example which
just shows a massive hypocrisy and
double standard is going on what do you
want if if you're a Palestinian and you
want to exist and you want to stop
living under constant occupation and
violence what are you supposed to do
Financial pressure that's bad violent
resistance that's worse I'm sure there
will be at least one angry person who
will watch this video and I want them
like literally I'm not just joking I
want you to tell me what the
Palestinians should do what's the right
thing that they could do the only answer
I seem to think that follows from the
logic that these people talk about is to
die that's the only thing they seem to
want what does an end to this even look
like I
am unfortunately an anti-d Doomer so
where are all the things that we can
anti-d Doom about again there are
multiple Solutions proposed the
two-state solution that we talked about
earlier that would make Israel and
Palestine independent but has a whole
range of other issues that we already
talked about and require tons of
concessions that at this point both
sides are not going to be willing to
give up and a lot of international
involvement and bilateral agreements
would have to happen again very
difficult there's of course the two
genders of the one-state solution
there's like the one that I like where
you turn you know Israel into a
multifaith democracy that ensures the
rights of Israelis and Palestinians or
the one-state solution that comes to me
in my anxiety dreams that at one day
Israel is just going to Annex both the
West Bank and Gaza and kill and displace
anyone who remains there's also the
three state solution which I don't
imagine is also viable where the West
Bank would be given over to Jordan and
the Gaza Strip given over to Egypt but
for several different reasons that have
to do with geopolitics neither country
is interested in taking that land and
again it doesn't address the issue of
the 50% of the West Bank being taken up
by illegal Israeli subers then there are
also other attempts to build more
Regional cooperation things like the
Abraham s to try and work together as an
entire Middle East to collaborate on
making a peaceful situation or maybe
some sort of scenario where Palestinians
aren't independent per se but have some
kind of regional autonomies sort of
something akin to what the Kurds have in
Iraq this would require Palestinians to
have access to the world to give them
infrastructure development and give them
the resources they need to actually be
self running and autonomous but again
all of these would require people
especially Israel to take some
accountability for their actions and
instead of overstating harm followed by
a brutal backlash which then causes a
backlash you just end up with an endless
cycle that doesn't seem to end we would
need to stop it in its tracks the more
powerful party Israel has to be the
first one to do that and with this
government I feel like that's a long
ways away I think that the main solution
at this point would involve just Israel
not having a choice but to come to the
table through International pressure
campaigns if there's any hope it's the
idea that big moments like what's
happening right now can sometimes be
opportunities to break a status quo and
put in something better and I think
right now we got to do that I should
also mention that Jeremy has a really
amazing substack where he covers many
topics uh especially Canadian and
Alberta politics but he covers all sorts
of stuff as well and I'll put a link in
the description where you can check it
out he also has a book coming out next
month that I wanted to draw some
attention to it's a book about Jason
Kenny so if you're maybe really
interested in Alberta politics and the
rise and fall of Jason Kenny he has that
book it's called Kenny ISM comes out on
comes out on March 5th I pre-ordered my
copy maybe you can get one too because
he's really smart and the stuff he makes
is excellent anyways see you guys next
time